sí
estamos listos para el paso 2 en nuestra
búsqueda por la fórmula alusiva de cómo
calcular un punto exacto en una parábola
para ganar un poco de intuición
regresemos el interactivo que usamos
para iniciar todo esto aquí tenemos mi
construcción con un montón de líneas y
ahora déjenme pasar por todas las líneas
una por una resaltando las en rosa aquí
tenemos una aquí otra y aquí otra y cada
una de estas líneas de color rosa puede
ser descrita por una fracción tema que
identifica este punto en la línea
conforme muevo la línea rosa atrás hacia
delante observen que continúa tocando la
parábola exactamente en un lugar
si pudiera encontrar una fórmula para
saber qué lugar es ese esa sería la
fórmula que estoy buscando podemos ver
esto aún más claro en esta versión del
interactivo que usarán en un momento
para resolver algunos ejercicios
entonces en esta versión puede usar el
parámetro temp
para ver de qué línea de construcción
estoy hablando y observen que cada una
de las líneas que estoy construyendo
toca a la parábola exactamente en un
lugar en el siguiente ejercicio les
pedirán que obtengan una hipótesis para
saber cuáles es el lugar y la hipótesis
como adelanto tiene que ver con la
relación entre estos subsegmentos
creados y pusimos códigos de colores en
estos subsegmentos para ayudarles un
poco más entonces vean si pueden
resolver cuál es la relación especial